and finally new rule football is a body
crushing brain wrecking game but we all
know that now so either ban it or shut
the hell up about it and I say that is
someone who is not callous to the
suffering when I see a receiver go over
the middle and get hammered
I always think one I hope that didn't
cause permanent damage and two did he
get enough for the first down cuz we
needed that play oh he didn't even hold
on [ __ ] what are we paying you for now
about a month ago Hollywood released a
movie about the evils of violence and
football concussion it was called
starring Will Smith and it tanked
possibly because Americans retain a
strong libertarian streak I want to come
to the game we're all gonna watch this
Sunday their view is let's make it a day
to enjoy one national pastime football
and set aside our other national pastime
with just telling strangers how to live
their lives
you know I I feel bad about the violence
if the reason I watched the game was to
see injuries you know like NASCAR but
that's not the reason I watch it because
it's a great game and an unfortunate
side effect is young men smashing into
each other like demolition derby cars
full of meat and loving it yes they do
seem to be loving it alpha males have
been fighting alpha males ever since the
first Greek teenager told his friend
let's take our clothes off and wrestle
it won't be gay at all
Paul Walker died joyriding now I don't
get car love I don't think driving is
like sex I think it's like commuting but
that's me
he was doing what he loved some people
smoked cigarettes some ski too fast some
date Chris Brown
oh yes yes Americans spent a lot of
their time working on relationships
unfortunately there are other people's
if Rihanna wants to get back with Chris
Brown or Hillary wants to say with Bill
that's their call not yours you don't
get you don't get to stop strangers from
doing what or who they love even if it's
not what or who you would do just days
after David Bowie's recent death someone
dug up an old interview with the retired
groupie named Laurie Maddox where she
said she lost her virginity to Bowie
when she was 15 in a hotel suite on hash
and champagne which in 1972 was
considered part of a complete breakfast
now to hear Laurie tell it she was a
more than willing partner and he was
gentle and knowing and wearing a kimono
which is not a bad way to lose your
virginity considering most D flowerings
involve Michelob of an and crying if
there's a victim here
it's the poor guy who had to [ __ ] Laurie
Maddox next how do you follow David
Bowie in a kimono talk about pressure
pushing me down but according to the
Internet social justice warriors this
was horrible and Laurie would be better
off today if she'd lost her virginity to
a loser named Dan from algebra 2 class
sure Laurie says she loved it and still
loves it and has never regretted for a
second but she's wrong because she's
only asking herself she should be asking
a blogger or a woman's collective in
Winnipeg because they know better than
Laurie how Laurie should feel you know I
thought we'd all come to accept this
mantra' live in the moment but sometimes
when you're young and in the moment the
moment includes recklessness who can say
that when they were young and felt
invincible they didn't do stuff that
compromised their health later on I
certainly did and I paid a fool the tale
in 1983 when we used to say that who
would have tried to take the Jack
Daniels out of my hand and can I say
with certainty that there will be no
consequences from a lifetime of pot
smoking no I can't but fortunately I can
treat them with medical marijuana
this guy is the same age as this guy
and yes Newt will probably live a little
longer but there's a downside to that he
has to live longer as Newt Gingrich
Sammy Davis jr. died at 64 because he
lived a fast fun rat packing life and
when he died I remember saying I would
rather have 64 Sammy years than a
hundred chemstar years well now I'm 60
and I strongly disagree
but you can only live at the age and
time you're living just try telling a 20
year old not to do something because how
they'll feel about it at 50 since
forever 20 year olds have been saying 50
the planet might not be here when I'm 50
and now they kind of have a point and by
the way I also lost my virginity at 50
and also to David Bullock